all right people of the internet I'm
Dave ruin this is the Ruben report it's
October 23rd 2020 3 we're live streaming
on Rumble YouTube and locals tap that
notification Bell if you have not and if
you want to join us for the postgame
Ruben report.
locals.com before we start quickly want
to address something that I touched on
for uh just 20 seconds or so on Friday
uh you know we're now I guess into the
third week of this Insanity what really
is worldwide insanity but emanating
after these Hamas attacks in Israel and
uh over the last couple weeks obviously
we have a whole bunch of new viewers and
I'm seeing that our stuff's being shared
all over the place and I know like a
little truth and a little sanity and a
little decency I guess goes a long way
in in a weird wacky dishonest time um so
I'm very happy that you guys are all
here I do want to say one thing though
I've been you know emotionally it's been
kind of difficult like figuring out how
to do this show every day and you know
I'm I'm always happiest when when the
show is funny and silly and all that
other stuff and we've tried to weave in
a little bit of that here and there but
on the emotional side of things I know I
have cursed more in last two weeks then
then probably if you took all the
f-bombs and other uh Choice language
over the years of the show I think I've
packed in more in these two weeks than
ever before right if you were just doing
a side by side on all that I am going to
try to control that starting this week
if I drop an F bomb during a show uh it
will it will be really really warranted
I've heard from a couple people first
it's funny because a lot of you love it
when I do it right and I'm just doing
like it's just coming out of me I'm not
sitting here like I'll drop F bomb here
and whatever it really is just like
emoting in real time and I know a lot of
you like it because you're feeling the
same way and you don't see news anchors
on television or pundits on television
that ever remote properly about anything
right they're all like these
pre-programmed robots um so some of you
really like it and then I've seen some
other people like oh but I want to show
this to my to my sister and my aunt and
my grandma and blah blah blah blah blah
so I'm going to try to do it as
professionally as possible I warn you
every now and again it's going to happen
but let's see we can get through a show
today with that one let's just see if we
can do it uh anyway uh Today's Show uh
obviously I'm going to get you caught up
on on all the latest the specifics on
the ground and how the media is just
screwing up everything and and what I've
really been focused on for the last two
weeks that this this woke mind virus
that so many of us have been trying to
expose for years is so deeply connected
to now what's happening on college
campuses and these insane protests that
we're seeing where they're in essence
calling for genocide this odd
intersectional monster where you've got
trans people for Palestine like all all
of the wackiness uh how the climate
change thing is even somehow connected
to this yes climate change for Palestine
because when they chop up those water
pipes uh and turn them into Rockets
somehow Greta thunberg is into that uh
so we're goingon to talk about who
pedals all this nonsense and is there
actually an alternative that's what
we're going to be doing today before we
do a fitting sponsor for you my Patriots
apply guys uh the unthinkable does seem
like it's here with all the recent media
distractions most of us never saw it
coming but some did and their guts told
them something was wrong and the
headlines are kind of proving them right
our so-called trusted institutions tell
you not to worry that everything's fine
but you guys probably know a bit better
than that uh you know self-reliance
doesn't happen overnight you have to
start somewhere start with my Patriot
Supply my Patriot Supply is the
country's largest preparedness company
and they're more than equipped to stock
your shelves ditch the canned vegetables
and Boxed Pasta their bestselling
three-month food kit provides delicious
breakfasts lunches and dinners that last
up to 25 years these meals offer over
2,000 calories every day with the
balance of protein and carbs to keep you
fed and ready in the event of an
emergency just add water and heat and
eat start or strengthen your food supply
with this three-month food kit from my
Patriot Supply visit prepare withth
ruben.com and get ready order now with
fast and free shipping prepare with
ruben.com and now back to Reuben okay so
one of the the slivers of people that
you know I focus on all the time when I
always from an election perspective is
who can move right if we if we even
remove these last couple weeks of events
who is it with this presidential
election coming up that might be able to
move and I've been saying for a long
time it's those disaffected Libs it's
the guys like me from years ago who kind
of woke up to the lunacy of the Democrat
Party now if we Flash Forward to
everything that's happening in these
last two weeks I think an awful lot of
Liberals are waking up and they they're
realizing the radicalism of the Democrat
Party and they're radical they're
realizing how BLM which was a complete
farce from the beginning and actually a
violent organization that was
terrorizing our streets how basically
overnight they flipped it into somehow a
pramas organization so good liberals and
there are even if you're a staunch
conservative watching this you know that
there are good liberals that there
certainly were good liberals JFK was a
good liberal right everyone knows this
the the battle in America used to be
from say a little more of a traditional
conservative usually a more religious
person and a liberal who was not
completely insane and woke and crazy but
maybe wanted a little bit bigger
government to kind of help on the
margins that was a that was what a
healthy America had for at least a
century right uh but because that group
now is waking up right a whole bunch of
them are like whoa whoa whoa we're
Democrats but we're not for beheading
children uh I think it is worth trying
to welcome them with open arms uh Bill
Maher yeah I'm starting with Bill Maher
today uh is one of those guys and I
don't know that he will ever get to the
finish line but he is now consistently
repeating things that conservatives have
been saying for years so here he is
talking about going to college
specifically Ivy Leagues by the way he's
he went to an Ivy League College himself
he went to to Cornell not too far from
where I went Sunni bton although he's
got a couple years on me uh but here he
is once again waking up sort of slow
motion conservative decent liberals
eventually coming around to the more
conservative position and I think
that'll set us up nicely for today's
show go and finally newal as an Ivy
League graduate who knows the value of a
liberal education I have one piece of
advice for the Youth of America don't go
to
college and if you absolutely have to go
don't go to an elite College because as
recent events have shown it just makes
you
stupid there are few of any positives to
come out of what happened in Israel but
one of them is opening America's eyes to
how higher education has become
indoctrination into a stew of bad ideas
among them the simplistic notion that
the world is a binary place where
everyone is either an oppressor or
oppressed in the case of Israel
oppressors being babies and bbas the
same students who will tell you that
words are violence and silence is
violence were very supportive when Hamas
terrorists went on a rape and murder
Rampage worthy of the Vikings they knew
where to point the fingers at the
murdered and then it was off to ethics
class 34 student groups at Harvard
signed a letter that said the apide
regime is the only one to blame proving
they don't know what constitutes apar
they don't know much of anything
actually but it doesn't deter them from
having an opinion they've convinced
themselves Israel is the most repressive
regime in history because they have no
knowledge of history or even a desire to
know it and actual history doesn't come
up in their intersectionality of
politics and gender queer identities
class okay so I know you're probably at
the same time having two emotions
watching that you're going oh it's nice
you're waking up and you're probably
also thinking oh you're probably not
going to get to the Finish Line bill
because he probably will vote for a
democrat in the end so I don't want to
make this about the partisan part what I
want to make this about is he as I
always often say he's sort of an avatar
for the last liberals and they can
change and what he is now saying this
idea of don't go to college and their
indoctrination Center and you know I
always say it's like they they send you
to College college used to be where you
learn how to think not what to think
it's become completely Revere they know
nothing of History they they say these
crazy words of oppressed and oppressor
and parthe and all these things and and
none of it means anything we're going to
show you some specific examples of how
confused they are in just a moment uh
but the point is for him to say to his
audience and and the millions of people
who watch don't go to college you know
when he said that the audience didn't
know what to do there was that pause and
then a couple people kind of appla Ed
but this has been a conservative opinion
for a long time that colleges are
indoctrination centers how did we get
here 7 years ago when I was going to
college campuses and me and Jordan
Peterson and Ben Shapiro and all those
like scary right-wingers when we were
going to college campuses and being
called Nazis and racists and we'd have
to have security everywhere we went it
was like everyone used to say to me Dave
Dave don't oh it's just college kids
stop making such a big deal about it but
over time over decades all of those
college kids who had their brains broken
in college and learned all of the worst
ideas they ended up in the real world
and they end up at companies and they
import all these woke ideas and now look
at all of our institutions so the fact
that he is out there now saying what is
a I mean think about it if you just
think about it from a purely political
perspective don't go to college no
Democrat would want you Democrats want
everyone in college right they want you
in debt they want you in college debt so
then they can come back and say ah we
solved your debt and they want you
indoctrinated because they know where
where when Bernie says well we should
have free college for everybody right
it's like does Bernie really want you to
learn the plethora of ideas does he
really want you to get a true education
the Socialists or do they know the best
place to get their their - tested wrong
ideas steeped into the brains of young
people would be at college right College
used to make you think outside of the
box that was the idea now it makes you
think inside of the box that is what
they are doing and it and it's rotting
an entire generation which we will get
to uh we'll get to some specific example
some specific examples of in just a sec
let me talk to you guys about the
satellite phone store guys fires
hurricanes tornadoes they can happen
almost anywhere and your cell phone
could go down as a result but not a
satellite phone satellite phones will
always work because you're carrying your
personal cell tower everywhere and
anywhere you go on Earth anyone who has
a satellite phone in the affected areas
of Hawaii the neev Nevada desert Etc has
a way to communicate with with friends
family and Emergency Services prepare
for the unexpected the most secure way
to communicate is from a satellite phone
to a satellite phone you can't be
tracked and no one can listen in on your
calls even the US military uses
satellite phones for secured
communication so here's a deal for you
visit sat1 23.com or call 866 3201 1884
and use promo code Dave 50 to wave the
$50 activation fee the services only
applicable to those in the USA again
just visit sat1 123.com use promo code
Dave 50 to wave the $50 activation fee
or call 866 3201 1884 and now back to me
okay so why would Bill Maher now Bill
Maher who went to an Ivy League school
who is a a a liberal elitist I don't I
don't even mean that in a judgmental way
I mean he's a Hollywood guy he's worth
probably 100 million bucks like that I
don't begrudge him any of those things
right but he's a liberal he's a liberal
thought leader why would he be saying
hey liberals cuz that's who is audiences
don't send your kids to these
indoctrination centers because and the
reason obviously is because he is now
seeing that liberalism seemingly cannot
stand up against wokeism now I'd like to
show you a tweet from Greta thunberg who
is a true wizard uh Greta of course the
climate I almost I would had a funny one
there but I didn't I'm not saying
it damn she's a climate chick uh here
she is a tweet from her week 270 today
we strike in solidarity with Palestine
and Gaza the world needs to speak up and
call for an immediate ceasefire Justice
and freedom for Palestinians and
civilians affected just just leave it up
for a second first look how happy these
chicks are all these people end up
endlessly miserable Greta thumber how
old is she she's like 15 she looks like
she's 72 right like they all end up with
that frumpled brow and just miserable
there just there's just misery and hate
there this Jew stands with pales sign
yeah go go to Gaza lady okay uh
anyway the climate activists you might
go well wait a minute what do the
climate activists have to do with Gaza
also she say she say she says she stands
with Gaza and Palestine saying you stand
for Palestine or what's going on between
Palestine and Israel makes no sense it
would be like saying what's going on in
Israel versus Israel because as you know
there would never was a state of
Palestine right okay fine I I accept
that they're all just kind of ridiculous
but you look at these young people and
you go well why are young people
rampaging through these colleges why are
they out on the street why are they
screaming there's a genocide when if you
look we're going to show you a graph in
a second the population of Gaza is
exploding it's going up this way right
um why are they so confused about all of
these issues well it's because of that
education thing that bill Mah was
referencing so now I want to show you
this video this is a spectacular video
that I saw over the weekend it's by a
guy by the name of ysep Hadid he is an
isra he's an Israeli Arabs so he lives
in Israel he's Arab not Jewish full
equality he was a member of the IDF the
Israel Defense Forces uh and he is the
CEO of a of a nonprofit called together
vouch for each other which is an
organization that's devoted to Bringing
Arabs and Jews together in Israel so
here he is uh are we're showing his
video now right yeah so here he is uh at
a this what do you call this thing it's
like uh one of these Palestine booths
you know they've got these no are we not
doing
that oh sorry there's two things we're
doing here we're first going to he
created this video uh of Greta you're
going to remember this famous Greta
video uh from way back when about
climate change and watch how he fiddled
with it to uh to make it effective this
is all wrong I shouldn't be up
here I should be back in
school how dare you you have stolen my
dream dreams in my childhood with your
empty words and yet I'm one of the lucky
ones people are suffering people are
dying how dare you continue to look away
you say you hear us and that you
understand the urgency if you really
understood the situation and still kept
on failing to act then you would be evil
and that I refuse to believe how dare
you pretend that this can be sold with
just business as usual you are failing
us we will not let you get away with
this right here right now is where we
draw the
line the world is waking up and change
is coming whether you like it or not
thank
[Applause]
you as you can see very clever what he
did right there like when you take her
words and then you apply them to this
things are a little bit different the
other video that I was referencing he
went to one of these booths you know
they've got these booths at these
college campuses where these people are
all pro paltin and he just gets into it
with one of these people and they just
don't know what they're talking about
which is a perfect segue to this next
video uh this is a video of a Norwegian
student in Poland and check out her
poster and then an interviewer goes up
to her to ask her a bit more about what
she thinks about this conflict hello
girls uh tell me where you from and why
did you came out today h I'm from Norway
I study here in Poland but I'm here
to to support the Palestinian and people
and their rights
and hopefully there will be a free
Palestine so you holding such a postal
keep the world clean uh I say from juice
yes no not juice not juice no juice no
of course not juice uh really freedom of
relig religion is also a human right
which we support uh but we do not
support the Israeli governments and the
ethnical genocide they're doing right
now um to the Palestinian people H but
Jews we love everyone love Jews and
Christians and
Muslims God it's it's incredible I'm
going to be showing a lot of these types
of videos I think going forward to just
show you how these people have no idea
what they're talking about uh so there's
a lot of things I could nitpick there
right um let's start with this this idea
that Israel is committing genocide and
there has been a
75e genocide of the Palestinian people
check out this chart and and you should
check it out on your own don't take my
word for it you can do a little Googling
the population of Gaza from
1960 to now it has basically uh not not
tripled it is five times 5x basically
from about a million to 5 million people
uh this is the worst genocide of of all
time uh obviously uh when you're
committing genocide the population is
going to go down genocide would be
something like what the Germans did to
the Jews in the Holocaust right six
million people it goes down and then all
of what those people were going to have
babies and everything else you lose
generations of people in a genocide
there there simply is no genocide also
it's a very clear and this is this is
one of the tricks They're all playing
they're not going after Jews right it's
not about Jews sure I've got the Jewish
star in a garbage can it's not about
Jews it's about those Israelis it's the
Israeli government those are the mean
guys and she wants a free Palestine but
they'll never really Define what that
means what she means I think in essence
and what they really do mean especially
because so many of them are chanting
from The River To The Sea right the
Jordan River to the Mediterranean SE
that is the whole of Israel we would
like to take all of these people out so
what is this
oddly not religious what is this oddly
cult-like behavior of Greta thunberg who
doesn't say anything about babies being
burned and and women being beheaded by
the way the Israeli government this
morning they did an hour press
conference with with about a hundred
International journalists to show some
of the images that they've been holding
back and show some camera footage that
soldiers had you know when they have
little cameras on their on their outfits
and everything and there are beheadings
and like it's it's all of the worst
unimaginable stuff people that are that
are tied together that are you know with
metal metal metal wiring that were
burned alive and like
yeah all of the stuff you know all that
but why is it there's no sympathy for
that why is it that a you know
1300 iselis are killed in Cold Blood and
suddenly worldwide everyone's screaming
about free Palestine even though there's
not one Jew or Israeli or settlement in
Gaza right Hitler would love the place
well it's partly because
intersectionality has made everybody
stupid and where do they teach
intersectionality it's at the colleges
so again Bill Maher is right so you end
up with these woke trans activists who
are out there protesting for a group of
people Hamas and the Palestinian
movement as a whole who would gladly
behead them so speaking of uh trans
activists uh here is a trans activ
there's a didn't want to curse
there's a lot of these videos out there
this is just one here's a trans activist
explaining how being Trans in America is
very similar to being
a gazin during a war go I keep getting
comments that if I was in Gaza I would
be killed for being queer and first off
there are queer people in Gaza and
they're being killed for being
Palestinian secondly I don't need to
move across the ocean to experience
violence for being queer I literally had
to evacuate my place 6 months ago
because people were so violent and
sending me death threats literally
hunting me down for being trans this is
in the United States of America the
United States of America for Trans
people is in stage 7 and 8 Palestine is
in 9 and 10 there is a reason why the
United States was the only country who
vetoed a United Nations security Council
resolution there is a reason why our
government is so adamant about saying
level the place there is a reason why
this country continues to ignore what's
happening in Palestine because our
country is built on genocide and by the
way Hitler he also attacked queer people
there's a reason why we were forced to
wear pink triangles and also he
literally got his ideas for
concentration camps from the United
States of America history is repeating
itself right now and how dare you try to
weaponize my queerness in order to
manipulate me to support genocide I will
never stand by Israel's actions I won't
stand by Israel in general and if you
are queer and you are standing with
Israel you're wrong and you really need
to take a step back and evaluate your
morals and value look frankly I don't
think you need me to analyze any of that
so instead I'd like to show you a 10 or
15 second video that I found of that
dude putting on his
makeup oh this is just feel look
fabulous looking and a little more on
the cheeks a little
more like do I have to add commentary to
what we just saw it's all so stupid
anyway here's a dude in add dress
leading a pro Palestine protest in
Washington
DC free free Palestine free free
Palestine free free Palestine free free
Palestine free free
palese all right I want to be very clear
about this if any of you know who that
man in a dress is who's also wearing a
mask outdoors I have no idea why uh I
will put
$10,000 I am not kidding $10,000 to send
that man in addess to Gaza you know what
$20,000 I you know what I mean fly first
class I'll get you a couple nice dresses
we'll get you some anol o blonic that's
a type of shoe Jimmy choose whatever you
want and I'd like to send you to Gaza
you masked dude in a dress screaming for
people who would love to behead you it
is it is so extraordinary like if you
can't see what's going on right now and
that that's again I do think there is a
silver lining Happening Here there
really is something happening here I
know everything seems worse right now
right like there there's something
unbelievably horrific happened and and
there's now still Fallout from that and
there's there's we could potentially be
on the verge of World War III there's an
existential battle happening right now
like there's all of that but the Silver
Lining is good decent people who I get
it they're quiet they're not out there
protesting and screaming so we're only
seeing the crazies but good decent
people see videos like that and they get
they get what's going on so now I want
to show you uh what's happening across
the world because we're seeing these
crazy dudes in dresses screaming for
free
Palestine I want to just say Joan Rivers
by the way like who's better than Joan
you give me Joan Rivers and Miss Piggy
any day they're they would be better
political analysts than what you're
seeing on CNN anyway all over the world
right now we are seeing these these
crazy they're Pro Hamas protests they're
not pro Palestine protests okay they're
just not there is no one at these
protests that is like guys Hamas was bad
I'm for the Palestinian people but Hamas
was bad no they are suddenly all
screaming from The River To The Sea
they're talking about the end of a 75e
occupation which as I always say is odd
because seemingly 75 years ago that's
when the British Empire was there there
never was a state of Palestine so they
they want the British to come back I
don't know any British people who want
the British Empire to come back um but
all over the place and and London has
been a hot bed for this there are
hundreds of thousands of people out on
the streets I don't know how you could
be a Jewish person or anyone who loves
the west or or a true British citizen uh
and feel safe in in London right now
there are these massive there are calls
for Jihad and that they should be have
Muslim armies take over the world and
everything else but look what the
British police are up to they found two
white guys with an Old English flag and
they're not happy with
them for the moment anything racist or
even close to racism is
said let me finish let meish moment
anything gets anything close that right
people are going to start getting
arrested it's just it's just a verbal
warning you know it's a verbal warning
to the guys holding the old flag of
England right most people think of the
of the UK flag that's the old flag
England yeah it's the well it's the
current flag of England but people think
of the British flag right the UK flag
and those guys are the ones who have to
worry about being racist there are
literally people out there saying kill
all the Jews River to the Sea like who
is more indigenous it's those hundreds
of thousands of people who have been
imported into England who are calling
for a worldwide caliphate or or is it
the Jews in the ancient land of Israel
like again it's just like just if you've
got any brain cells left and I know you
do if you're watching this it's like you
can just see the truth and hopefully
spread it a little bit more but this
this radicalism that's and it's
happening in Paris and it's happening in
Brussels and all over the place uh it is
leading to to genuinely bad things not
only that millions of people no longer
feel safe in their homes and in their
communities uh but this is out of
Detroit so this is from uh Rashida
talib's District now Rashida Talib as
far as I'm concerned she is a member of
the Hamas caucus she is a Hamas
supporter she has no problem with as
many dead Jews I think she's radically
anti-American I think if the Democrats
had any balls they would figure out a
way to censure her at least at the very
least uh but really probably kick her
out of Congress but the party is is just
an abject disaster at this point um well
in her very District uh the president of
a synagogue outside of Detroit was found
stabbed to death over the weekend uh a
little clear what might have Happ
unclear what might have happened turning
now to the Urgent investigation underway
in Detroit after the murder of a
synagogue president police say Samantha
wall was found stabbed to death outside
her home this weekend officials say all
possible motives are being investigated
authorities tell ABC News no evidence
has surfaced to suggest the killing was
motivated by anti-Semitism ABC's Alex
pche is in Detroit
tonight tonight authorities in Detroit
on high alert after the brutal murder of
the president of a local synagogue
Detroit police say Samantha wall was
found around 6:30 a.m. Saturday outside
her home The 40-Year-Old stabed multiple
times a trail of blood leading back to
her townhouse she was pronounced dead at
the scene wool had led the Isaac a
synagogue in downtown Detroit since last
year I'm just numb at this moment you
know Sam was such an amazingly kind
person um I can't imagine anything like
this happening to her late today wool's
body laid to rest her family remembering
her as a beautiful soul our world is
shattered without you you brought us
light randomly stabbed multiple times we
we don't know if it's anti-Semitism I'm
sure that the mainstream media would run
it the same way if it was the president
of a mosque like which of course would
be equally horrific right you cannot
kill innocent people because of blood
lust from across the world but when a
member of Congress is out there
basically excusing right Rashida TB is
it's not that she's basically excusing
she is in essence cheering on the blood
lust of Hamas and then suddenly randomly
a president of a synagogue and District
gets stabbed to death on the street I
guess we'll have to figure out what that
means but it's not just Rashida TB right
none of the squad and we've shown you
plenty of videos of AOC she has no idea
what she's talking about relative to the
geography or the history right she is
LARPing as a congresswoman she is an
actress like a complete buffoon actress
but here I want to show you ilhan Omar
who is I would say it's it's hard to
decide you know AOC is kind of the worst
because she's the most influential
Rashida is like a genuine like America
hating evil person and and ilhan I I
don't know how you you have to figure it
out for yourself like there's good
arguments Every Which Way on who's the
worst of the three of them but here's a
journalist in the capital trying to uh
ask ilhan om if Hamas is bad did they do
anything bad like she could just turn
and say yeah beheading children is bad
but no she can't do
it you for a ceasefire are you okay with
Hamas terrorists continuing to
exist do you think that Israel should
just lay down their arms and not try to
get the hostages out of Gaza
how can Israel have a ceasefire with
terrorists whose entire mission is to
wipe out their exist please BL elev how
can they have a seire if they're trying
to wipe out this crazy lady don't worry
ignore this crazy lady don't worry about
her those are all completely legitimate
questions and you have to understand
ilhan Omar does support Hamas how hard
would it be for her even if she doesn't
believe it like if she was smart and
doesn't believe let's say it is my
belief and I think it's fairly obv
obvious the evidence proves it that she
supports himas she would gladly I think
she would gladly gladly have those 8
million Jews killed you'd have to kill a
whole bunch of Israeli Arabs she would
be fine with another genocide I think
she deeply hates America she came here
ascertained incredible power she's
destroyed Minnesota okay fine but how
hard would it be if she was just like
trying to be a little bit better not
even trying to be a little bit better if
she was trying to be a little more
clever for her own side shouldn't she
just turn to the person and say well of
course you know Hamas beheading children
is bad but I but I stand up for the
people of Gaza like that wouldn't be
that hard to say but she won't even give
an inch on that and nobody in the
Democrat Party nobody has the balls to
say anything about it now you might go
well why is that the and the problem
with the Democrat Party is not only has
it been captured by these radicals as
you know but the guy up top we are to
believe that Joe Biden is is in charge
of the Democrat Party and I just don't
know how at this point after these years
of of watching him stammer and stumble
through everything and fall up the
stairs which again is always a skill
unto itself most people fall down the
stairs he usually Falls up the stairs
how anyone could think he is in charge
so we don't know who really is in charge
a lot of people think it's the Obama
machine and everything else but we know
that Biden would never put down the
radicals in his own party so he gave a
he gave a talk at the Oval Office uh and
you know he managed to read off the
teleprompter like kind of I'll give
credit where credit do like for him it
wasn't like the most slur thing ever
what are they doing to his face I think
this is worth noting we know that they
are drugging him Beyond imagination but
they're also pumping him all full of
things which is why sometimes it looks
like he has testicles hanging off his
chin sometimes his fa like what is going
on here but also listen to the words see
tell me if what he says here is does
this really seem like it's the issue at
the moment if you're if you're watching
this is what he's really referencing
here and the hate in this country and
who it's aimed at is this really the
problem right now take a look you know I
know many of you view in the Muslim
American Community the Arab American
Community the Palestinian American
community and so many others are
outraged and Hardy saying to yourselves
here we go again with islamophobia and
distrust we saw after
911 just last week my mother was
brutally stabbed a little boy here in
the United States okay first off nobody
should be brutally stabbed we cannot
bring sectarian violence from across the
world over here but when you see all
those protests when they're screaming
from the sea River to the Sea and all
that the Stark difference between the
what are generally smaller protests
because people are nervous to be out
there supporting Israel and supporting
America I mean at the at the Israel
protests the pro-israel protest they're
talking about bring our children home
they're talking about their love for
America their love for their country um
there is no chant of kill anybody or
erase anybody or anything else but that
he somehow makes it seem that
islamophobia is the problem right now
first off a phobia is an irrational fear
everywhere that Islam as a religion has
taken root in the in the world is not
good for any minorities be it women or
gays or religious minorities or anything
else right there's no flourishing
Christians in uh Islamic countries right
there's no flourishing Jews in Islamic
countries but his but
suddenly uh they they put the aim on
that oh we're worried about
islamophobia you would have a rational
fear if a whole bunch of people who were
saying we'd like to genocide those
people moved into your neighborhood that
would be a problem so there is no moral
Authority I guess that's what I'm trying
to say there's no moral honest Authority
in the Democrat Party to R to reign in
the radicals they're just simply isn't
but they keep putting the the spokes
people out there so that we don't so to
basically try to trick us like don't
worry like Biden really is in charge and
we have a good handle on all of this
here's former Biden Chief of Staff Ron
Clan explaining that Biden really is in
charge right now don't worry about any
of that sure well I don't want to color
it too much go ahead well I think they
were wise words from a wise president I
think he's just reminding the world and
the Israelis that the US did things that
regretted after 911 he's talked also
about combating islamophobia and
anti-Semitism here in our country so
it's a difficult time but we have a wise
experienced president leading the way
for us here in America guys he's wise
and inexperience he's he's wise and
experienced don't worry about Joe Biden
can't say two sentences without fumbling
makes up stories constantly makes up his
history deeply corrupt through his son
and a whole bunch of other stuff don't
worry and he's going to deal with all
that islamophobia you know what he's
also going to deal with he's also going
to deal with giving money to the people
who just uh caused all of this chaos
that's right we talked about it last
week we just released a 100 million of
new funding to the government of God
that is literally Hamas the people who
just did all of this who in their
Charter called for the genocide of the
Jews we just we just gave them a cool
hundred mil today I'm also announcing
$100 million in new US funding for
humanitarian assistance in both Gaza and
the West Bank this money will support
more than 1 million displaced and
conflict affected Palestinians including
emergency needs in
Gaza some extent I I don't know what to
say about this like we are funding
basically both sides of this and these
both sides are not equal one is a tiny
Democrat State trying to live by Western
values in its historic Homeland and
we're also funding the guys trying to
kill them how right now could we say so
he's making a distinction there right so
there's the West Bank which again it's
Judea and Samaria Judea means where the
Jews are from but they don't want any
Jews to live there okay fine again
that's where Jesus was from he he's a
pretty popular Jew Jesus right okay um
but they don't want any Jews living
there fine but he's making a distinction
so we're going to give a hundred million
to the government of Gaza and to the
West Bank so the government of Gaza
that's Hamas there there's no other guy
getting the money and by the way we
played all the videos last week of how
money is fungible right we give the six
billion back to Iran and they're like
well we're going to do whatever we want
with it and then our spokesman get up
there and like well money's fungible and
yeah when you give people money they can
do whatever they want with it so we're
giving money to Hamas we know they will
use it for weapons and everything else
and and God knows what they will use it
for and then I think maybe maybe maybe
not even that we have the money maybe
you could make an argument we should
give some money to the Palestinian
Authority and the West Bank because
they're not quite I mean they are
basically we played you the the thing on
was that Friday uh where they're issuing
statements kill all the Jews but they're
not like super duper kill all the Jews
all the time so maybe it keeps a little
like even try to rationalize it any of
this is completely insane uh but we're
given the money we know the money is
fungible and then we hand over the money
and then Biden State Department
spokesman Matt Miller admits that we
don't know what the hell they're going
to do with the money the the concern the
Israeli government has and they've said
this publicly and they certainly said it
privately to us is that any assistance
that goes in will be diverted once it's
inside Gaza that there is not a there's
not an Israeli military force in Gaza
there's not a Un Peace Keeping force in
Gaza the people with guns inside Gaza or
Hamas and so Hamas may try to divert
this assistance and keep it from getting
to the civilians who who it is intended
for we think that's a legitimate concern
uh We've made clear that this aid needs
to go to innocent civilians and not
Hamas we're going to be watching very
carefully how it's delivered um because
we want to be sensitive to those
concerns which we
share I I this this the whole show can
we title this show Dave doesn't know how
to comment on the stupidity like he's
admitting it the Israelis are like oh
Hamas is running the show you're giving
them a 100 million they have all the
guns we have no ability to manage what's
going on down there and what do you mean
so what what do you mean we're going to
make sure the money gets to the people
who need it like what does that mean
like the average G and okay here's 20
bucks good luck like what are we even
talking about we are literally paying
Hamas and they're they're fullon
admitting it and not only are they fully
admitting it Hamas right now still has
probably 20 to 30 American hostages okay
killed at least a dozen or a couple
dozen Americans uh we know where hamas's
leadership is in Qatar we haven't
demanded that they release the Americans
much less the 200 uh Israeli hostages or
anything else and here's Secretary of
State Tony blinkin uh there's at least
10 it sounds like there's about 10
unaccounted for American hostages I
don't know why we haven't asked anything
about them or anything but here he is do
you believe that all 10 uncounted for
Americans are being held
hostage uh Kristen we don't know as you
said we've got 10 unaccounted for
Americans uh we believe that uh some
significant number are hostages but you
know what's happening is and it just
underscore towards the har uh Israel
continues to discover uncover people who
were killed who were slaughtered and I
use that term very advisedly slaughtered
on October 7th so what we don't know for
sure is whether some of the um
unaccounted for are dead and have simply
not been uncovered yet or whether the
hostage but we we have a pretty strong
idea that some number of the 10 at least
are being held in in Gaza by Hamas her
next question should be so are you going
to do any about it you useless person in
an expensive suit are you going to do
anything about it we know that Qatar
houses all of the leadership of Hamas
why are we not leveraging that why
aren't we I don't know like I don't want
to get into a war but we could threaten
to blow up Qatar guys if you don't
freaking release the American hostages
we're going to blow up qar I'm not
calling for that but something why
aren't we putting sanctions on qar why
aren't we saying qar if you don't kick
out
the leaders of the group who are holding
our people you're going to have some
other
problem it's extraordinary the the level
of complete and utter incompetency by
this Administration and again I would I
would compare this to the border is it
complete an utter incompetence or is it
or is it genuine uh is it genuinely that
they are trying to destroy America from
the inside so you let everybody in on
from the border perspective and when it
comes to foreign policy it's like you
know well I don't know where the
Americans are we don't know how many
people there are we know kind of who's
in who's got them and how they got them
but we're just not going to we're just
not going to do anything but my suit is
pretty nice look at my suit and look at
Joe Biden he's so pumped full of
resellin right now my God look at his
plump face for 80 years old anyway the
other problem of course is that the
media just lies about everything Hamas
which is the governing Authority a
terrorist organization who in their
docks check the docks kill all the Jews
right their whole thing is ethnic
cleansing and genocide but anytime they
release any information oh a hospital
blew up 500 people were killed no it
turns out they blew up a parking lot
next to the hospital there was probably
about 10 people and we know that Hamas
has weapons there the mainstream media
just repeats Hamas talking points over
and over again thus leading a group of
really dumb young people dudes in
dresses with masks screaming for a free
Palestine when they have no idea what
they're talking about here's just a
compilation of Hamas disinformation
being spread by mainstream media but
there was a opportunity for missing
disinformation especially on social
media I caution you to be very careful
about what you choose to believe and on
what basis the horrific scene at a
hospital in Gaza today an explosion that
killed more than 500 people the
government in Gaza says the Israeli
Defense Forces struck a hospital in the
center of Gaza City an air strike hit a
Gaza City Hospital killing at least 500
people it's because of an alleged
Israeli air strike on a hospital in Gaza
that Hamas Health officials say killed
more than 500 people and when you're
talking about 500 people you have to
wonder how many of those people are
innocent civilians that minimum hundreds
of people have been killed in what they
say was an Israeli air strike where a
hospital was caved in killing hundreds
and stranding an Untold number under the
concrete by far the deadliest Israeli
air strike ever hundreds taking shelter
at a Gaza City Hospital were killed in
an Israeli air strike today Israel says
it was targeting Hamas hideouts
Palestinian officials saying at least
500 people killed in what they claim was
an Israeli air strike aftermath of an
alleged air strike on a Gaza hospital
that killed more than 500 people an
Israeli missile struck the hospital
absolutely horrific loss of life this is
not the first time B is actually hit
which supposed to be obviously a place
of healing deadly explosion at a
hospital in Gaza Palestinian officials
say hundreds were killed and they're
blaming Israel this was not a blast uh
this was not an explosion this was an
air strike it was a deliberate War crime
that Israel conducted on this Hospital
all right everything that you just heard
there was a complete lie we went through
this last week it was a rocket being
shot by Islamic Jihad into Israel and
about a quarter of their Rockets blow up
in Gaza so they've they've actually
about 500 rockets at least out of the
7,000 or so that they've shot Israel
have blown up in different parts of Gaza
no one even Al jazer is admitting that
it wasn't an Israeli air strike but
these people lie about everything and
then somehow uh a president of a
synagogue in Rashid tob's District at
stabed you might you might think that
these things are connected at some level
right but thankfully again more and more
people are seeing through the nonsense
but if you want to see just one more I
saw this one this morning this is just
so incredible put up this map from CNN
this is a map that CNN put up they have
Tel Aviv basically on the border of uh
Lebanon up there Tel Aviv is in the
middle of Israel that is completely
wrong and St root which they have in the
West Bank St root is right next to Gaza
in reality that's the place where in the
old days when the Rockets Couldn't Shoot
as far sto was the place that all the
Rockets would fall it's right next so
Gaza you can see there is in the South
by the Mediterranean Sea sto is down
there it is not in the West Bank Tel
Aviv is much more in the center of the
country and and CNN just puts this map
up they lie I don't even know what the
purpose of them lying about that was
right like H how did that possibly pass
these people I don't know what has
happened here like I know it at some
level they like it's it's years it's
Decades of indoctrination and broken
brains and hiring all the wrong people
that lead to that but who put that map
together and if that person is not fired
like what are you doing CNN and I guess
the question really is not what are they
doing it's like why are you
intentionally doing this uh Brock made a
good point the funniest out of that
compilation that we just showed you the
funniest thing that they reference is
Hamas Health officials what are Hamas
Health officials they Hamas literally
keeps bombs and their entire operational
Center is under the biggest hospital
when that woman's say it's a place of
healing a hospital oh we should tell the
people who are literally building bombs
and underground tunnels and everything
else beneath the hospital Hamas Health
officials it's Dr Muhammad Muhammad he's
the one that said you should behead
people a little bit lower on the neck
he's a health
official so what's the alternative to
corporate media what's the alternative
to the Endless Lies the people who have
gotten everything wrong who have lied
about history so that people have no
idea what's going on and then you have
dudes dresses calling for their own
beheadings in cities Across America and
across the world well the answer is that
you got to figure out other ways to get
information uh so I want to show you
this clip of of Joe Rogan now Rogan for
my opinion has not been good on Israel
he has for a long time just put on like
radical crazy leftist whatever I sense
he may be going through a bit of an
Awakening on this thing because he's
seeing the craziness right I'd be happy
to go on his show and explain the the
history of this uh if he wants me that
that would be fine but he could put on
anyone to do it doesn't have to be me
but he's been pretty bad on Israel over
the years um and and put on some of the
just really the worst people related to
all of this he had Coleman Hughes on
Coleman Hughes uh is a guy I've had him
on the show he happens to be black he's
an interesting thinker uh and Coleman
was laying out a pretty clear
explanation of there are kind of good
guys and bad guys here and the media's
been lying about the hospitals and
everything else and Rogan brought up
brought up how the left because they own
culture they've they've owned comedy
forever but even that is changing he's
talking about the onion and the Babylon
B specifically take a look New York
Times patiently awaiting Zoom call from
Hamas to see what they should print
today yeah so this is this is about the
hospital yeah that is the Babylon B
thank God they exist CU like they they
disprove the idea that it's only
left-wing people that are funny yeah
that is not true The Babylon B is they
out onion the onion often they're
amazing they much better than the onion
used to be great still is good they
still knocking out of the park every now
and again but you know they're young
Progressive liberals constrained by a
certain ideology that doesn't allow them
to poke fun at certain things you know
how much fun they could have like the
trans issue they they can't touch it
they can't touch it yeah yeah Rachel l v
they can't touch it leave it alone get
out of there it's too hot I'll clean
that up for you I mean the onion is
abject horrible it's woke trash and
nothing that is woke is funny the the uh
headline that they were reading can we
put it up there from The Babylon B this
is just great it illustrates everything
we were talking about before New York
Times patiently awaiting Zoom call from
Hamas to see what they should print
today and as you know when that hospital
uh bombing the Islamic Jihad bomb that
blew up and destroyed the parking lot
next to the hospital not 500 people and
all that New York Times three times
changed their headline also on the front
page of the New York Times they showed a
building that wasn't even the hospital
underneath the headline that was talking
about the hospital so again guys what I
want the takeaway to be on this Monday
is that I get it like you see those
protests and it's horrible and you see
these trans people for this and the
media lying about everything but good
decent people are waking up I'm also
seeing a whole bunch of good decent
people that are going out and buying
guns and figuring out how to take care
of themselves maybe know your neighbors
so you feel a little more Comfort at
home uh and and just keep exposing this
nonsense that's what you got to do uh
ladies and gentlemen if you'd like to
join us for the postgame show coming up
right now at Ruben report. locals.com
and if you have not subscribed yet on
Rumble please do uh you know at just at
any moment it literally feels like at
any moment to me I could say one thing
that ends the YouTube operation so it's
rumble.com rubben report see you for the
post game and we will be back
[Music]
tomorrow